استمدوا اسمهم تيمنا بالموسيقي الالمانيه
الشهير ريتشارد فاجنر يسمون انفسهم
الموسيقيين وهم مقاتلون عسكريون محترفون
سابقون ومتقاعدين
ها شركه عسكريه خاصه الا انها في الواقع
تحولت الى قوه ضاربه مسانده للجيش الروسي
تحول تدريجي بدا عام 2014 في اولى مهامها
في الدم بس ثم رصدت تعمل في سوريا عام
وليبيا 2016
وافريقيا الوسطى في 2017 ثم مالي وبعض دول
افريقيا وامريكا الجنوبيه
مع بدايه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بقيه في
وجودهم ميدانيا كما كان في اي صله لها
بفاكنر حتى اعلنت بشكل مفاجئ عملهم على
الارض
وتدريجيا تحولت فاجنر من ميليشيا لابا لها
الى حجر زاويه في القتال في اوكرانيا
برزت قدراته مقاتليفاجنر في معارك
السوليدار وبخموت هناك القتال حرب شوارع
تنام دورها ميدانيا نظرا لطبيعه التدريبات
التي يخضع لها مقاتلوها والتي تتضمن
فاعليه في حروب المدن والتعامل مع مقاتلين
غير نظاميين لا سيما ان الجيش الاوكراني
يستعين بدوره بمقاتلنا اجانب
بما يشبه جيش الظل لروسيا تنفذ ما لا
يستطيع الجيش النظامي فعله دون تكميد
الدوله خسائر معنويه
لا ترتبط رسميا بوزاره الدفاع الروسيه ولا
يعرف حجمه التنسيق بينهما ولا شكله كثر
الحديث في الاونه الاخيره عن خلاف بين
فاجنر وقوات الجيش الروسي ماذا فعل متحدث
باسم الكرم
الى نفي ذلك بشكل قاطع قائلا ان الجيش ينف
في مهمه مشتركه وان الجميع يقاتلون من اجل
وطنهم فخر فاجنر بانجازاتها الميدانيه
وايشاده موسكوا بها انتجت مواقف دوليه
جديده في التعامل معها
صنفت واشنطن فاجنر منظمه اجراميه دوليه
فرد ملكها يفجي لبريغوجن برساله ساخره
بعثنها للمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كوربي يساله عن الجرائم التي
ارتكبتها فاجنر بعد تصنيف واشنطن